you're not telling you you're not
encouraging her to change you know
there's a risk of diabetes are they
saying um diabetes is a 10 are they
saying asthma is a 10 I'm saying
depression is a 10. uh so yeah you could
say yeah you're a 10 but no one's there
when she's crying all alone and she has
all these health problems
but what happens to all that energy then
and it is really heartbreaking a student
and
and I've seen plenty of people who have
been obese and they've you know they've
made tick tocks and stuff and they say
um on The Tick Tock uh I've done this to
myself or I'm going to take
responsibility and then you see their
progression and there's so much happier
and they're not in that delusion